lifeless bodies cover the floor
in this hospital ward in the iraqi city
of nasseria
most of the victims had covet 19 but it
was a fire
that killed them relatives are now faced
with the grim task of identifying their
loved ones
moments before this was the scene
emergency crews tackled the fire as it
ripped through the building
amid chaos families desperately tried to
find survivors
what happened tonight at the hussein
hospital is a catastrophe
[Music]
it's a tragedy that's left me speechless
it's as though iraq has to suffer
anguish and calamities
desperation turned to anger at least two
police vehicles were torched by furious
protesters
they say the government's mismanagement
and neglect of medical facilities
are to blame
it's the second time this year a large
fire has killed coronavirus patients
at least 82 people died in a baghdad
hospital in april
when an oxygen tank exploded and sparked
a blaze
some analysts say not much has changed
since
politicians have they know that they
need to blame corruption and they're
going
you know rhetorically they'll come out
and say this is all bad
but their actions rarely go with their
worth they will continue
and that's why sadly this is not the
last time we're going to see iraqis
dying because of the decisions made by
their political leaders
the hospital ward opened three months
ago to help curb a surge of coronavirus
infections
but the fire raises questions about
iraq's fragile health system
and these families say they deserve
answers and
accountability katya lopez of the young
al jazeera